hello
Hydroponics
oh boy
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to dead space we're
gonna find out what this is don't you
worry I know you've been sweating over
it oh it's tissue
well you got something Isaac it's
let's call it a tissue sample from
Mercer's pet hunter careful
who knows what mad science went into
that thing
maybe I could find out figure out what
Mercer's up to I mean there has to be a
DNA scanner close by
yeah I mean
I I guess you're right can I switch my
objective and it would like tell me
where I'm supposed to go find kinds I
don't have any way to the mining deck
okay run through a DNA scanner track
objective okay here we go
so I'm tracking it now uh
I didn't know I could do that
learn something new every day
all right this way apparently
and by if I'm fast did you oh it's right
in here
of course chemical lab
hello
is this it oh no
he's dork
huh
okay
where are you taking me
ah
this seems pretty round about
oh baby whoa baby get stomped you
stupid baby
that's what you deserve
all right ah back down this way well it
would have been lovely to
is it gonna is it gonna make me go
through the the whole the whole ordeal
again oh I should have just whoosh I
shouldn't hesitate like that on that
thing
it's gonna make me do a whole nother
lockdown again
hello
okay thankfully it seems like that was
the only lockdown that I had to
experience so uh now I'm good
around the corner
was there something around the corner
down here have I been down here isn't
that the bathroom no don't be silly wait
what
what are you what oh it's a d oh this is
the scanner
this is weird
mining contractor
Aegis seven
registered physician Dr Charles Mercer
morning
severe DNA abnormalities found
rig tracking is available to trace
possible Contagion authorize Harris
what did Mercer do to you
authorized thinking logs and points of
interest to relocate her thank you for
your commitment to Public Health you're
welcome
what
find Harris's ICU bed
no no no I'm following up on this I
don't know what this is all about but I
am gonna follow it
I'm curious I I did not know anything
about the origins of this great big
hunter
but it would be cool to know I remember
some other logs that were talking about
Harris so and it seemed like in the
other logs Harris had some kind of
connection to all of this nonsense here
like some deeper uh understanding
a little close man if I try like a
deathless like hardest difficulty run I
am I'm gonna end up hitting that
hey what's up baby
where do you want me to go back in this
way right it's all the hallways all the
beds
whoa more babies
sorry baby
you gots to go I did leave a lot of
these dudes behind
but thankfully without the hunter it
does make it a little bit easier if only
it wasn't so goddamn dark maybe whoa hey
cool I didn't notice this is my
screaming panic
that's wonderful
also can I uh
what
dude you just doing that for fun What's
your deal can I get the light on I think
there's another door around here
what's the deal with that what is the
deal
can I get a light on I would love light
can I get some lights
ah okay
that's not light
is that light
is this is this light
is this light on
I guess that is light on wow okay you
think that the lights would do something
okay
great
time to find an ICU bed
again with this thing why oh that's why
uh they're on me
foreign
well I hate those things
activate
is this it
ah that was recording
here look up for me
[Music]
just a sliver of bone between us
beloveds
it won't be like ages seven than that
unpleasantness
wasn't nice when I
did that
this errand you want me to do in All
Storage
the miners won't like it
probably has narrow-minded
that's the miners and economies
is tormenting someone
[Music]
I don't believe this
oh gods
yeah they do
I'm ready
oh I see
bacteria
[Music]
oh God
I can see
the Market's closes
he's been trying to show me
they're hungry they're coming
they'll make us hold
up
I see it now
the marker speaks
we can answer
[Music]
in related Rich activity what An
Inconvenient moment for the recording to
stop
investigate or storage
but I can't because I couldn't possibly
get into the ore stores as probably was
disabled okay well that's fascinating
um yeah all these are like ore related
which I'm not there yet so I'm going to
go back
objective tract I'm going to go back to
tram maintenance I gotta go the long way
back it's a hell of a walk but here I go
no need for that no need for this no
need for any of this I'm just gonna pop
a save and then I'm gonna get over to
the mining deck I think that's where I
need to go wasn't it where I need to go
I don't really remember no air we're
about to die from Air no having we need
air
thank you very much
Georgia four relaxing Cooperative in
breakfasts perfect location for
sightseeing
lift biking and Hill hiking
I end breakfast that sounds delightful
where can I sign up for that
sounds way better than the crap you were
having me do before
all right
so somewhere here they said that there
was a route straight to Hydroponics I
don't remember seeing that when I was
down here but then again I was a little
bit afraid of everything so I don't know
if I would have seen it
but that being said oh ammo's still okay
I can still sell this and I'm just gonna
not gonna mess with anything
because I have been ruining my chances
by frittering away my wealth and I
shan't Fritter it
I shant
what I Shan do
let's go to Hydroponics
you know if I didn't know any better
I say it sounds like someone's taking a
shower
foreign
were you taking a shower
sorry to disturb if you were
all right
well
interesting horrifying I don't like any
of it there probably was various
security doors around here
I don't remember which one and where
that's a Slammy door wait wasn't there
like at the end of this hallway wasn't
there
a security door oh
my memory
oh good job me excellently done me
well done me
is that everything
that is everything
all right back on track no more mystery
showers please
okay
oh no am I gonna have to go in that
first very dark room I still am not able
to get in the cargo bay but
I probably gotta go back here
foreign
oh no different oh right there was a
Hydroponics thing and I did look at that
and I went that was weird
but I guess it's not that weird after
all because if you think trams and
hydroponics they're so closely related
Sciences
what's with this long hallway
I think that here's not safe to breathe
yeah I smell it look at the whole deck's
running I'm reading a huge amount of
food storage too big to be anything they
grow it looks like the source of the
poison gas that patient in medical
said something about creating an enzyme
right maybe the scientists left the
workstation open
maybe
Hydroponics log Dr Elizabeth cross now
that sprinklers are fixed we're working
close to maximum capacity all Flora is
thriving and food yield has created a
surplus and I had the Surplus packed up
so we could send it to the Colony the
captain Matthias is strictly important
in his no-fly order
it's ridiculous homogeneous complaints
lifting station lockdown
okay station lockdown is over
any goodies down there no not by the
looks of it
okay
so we're headed into Hydroponics now and
then we're gonna take care of some big
food problem I I think they said
something about killing a fruit they
open and be with you oh you really can't
see that blood till you shine a light on
it
that's weird
how how are they doing that
you can't see the blood at all
it's weird
that's weird
guy oh great okay you're really draining
my health there
okay
100 credits that was that was worth it
that was worth it
okay that's a little more worth it
okay well I'm glad I went into the
bathroom always glad to go in the
bathrooms
what why does that keep happening I hate
it
don't open that door they will they have
come
uh-huh okay I I read you loud and clear
I know exactly what you're saying
hello
I do upon this
oh boy
[Applause]
that's pathetic and that's cheap that's
not on me that's on you so
yeah
those things
not my fault
this is Dr Elizabeth cross
turn back
it's all gone
everything we grew
a team
[Music]
all dead
that monster
please leave get somewhere safe
if I can find a way to kill it somehow
Jacob
if you're hearing this
you know I have to try
you're the Elizabeth that that Jacob
Taylor dude was looking for ah I see
just a couple of Heroes you two also it
doesn't look like they're all dead
there's some alive here look shrooms oh
I don't want to listen to that twice so
I'm gonna get out of here
liquid nitrogen Supply depleted uh
okay maybe they were right about that
can I just do a little bit of a boopity
boopity save
and then I'm gonna go to
this store even though I'm not like I
have any more money than I just did when
I went there a second ago but maybe I
got something to sell I do thank you
uh
[Music]
uh oh I do like ammo but I'm okay I'm
Gonna Save money until I really need it
because that one always goes okay I got
liquid nitrogen
liquid nitrogen replenished
well that's convenient and easy
usually it's a multi-step process where
I gotta go to a and then go to B and get
C
oke well God damn that was that was nice
yeah I finished the inside it's been
modified to digest something big they
must have been trying to kill whatever's
in food storage
let's hope it works
yeah let's hope something tells me it
kind of Spilled Out a little bit
it's all kinds all over the walls
spines too for some reason but
I'm an engineer not a doctor I'm not
going to question it anyway only one way
to go do
it
maybe I should buy more ammo no I'm fine
[Music]
you're Elizabeth cross right this
Leviathan is that much poisoning the air
the air my team has destroyed everything
I designed a special enzyme to kill it I
just needed liquid nitrogen to complete
the synthesis
to the people I sent to Medical
never came back I've got some of that
enzyme here
ow
en we need to inject it into the
Leviathan
you can't get into food storage but
there's another way it's risky
riskier than running out of air
19 has been
altered
they're all connected to the Leviathan
breathing out its toxins
the connection goes both ways okay so if
I get to your team and inject them the
enzyme will be carried right into the
leviathan's heart
bind the
wheezers
okay sounds like a good plan you got it
pal
all right so long as I don't have to go
all over the place with yada yada and
blue blue inject Weezer one plus five
more
there's eight wheezers
oh man you tell me there's eight
wheezers all over this place all right
I'll get them
whatever all right in here you know it
all right all right come here wheezers
Gucci Gucci goo our aim
uh
oh that's probably not good
is that
what's what's the what's the purpose
what's the purpose
hello weapon upgrade ah who cares
how do I know when it's gonna spray me
it's spring now
any weezers in here whoa
you sack of crap
all right what else do I got here
uh level three upgrade ascended okay
cool Power node salvaged I have five I
like that
k-i-r grab range oh well that might be
nice Stacy's duration would be good
honestly all this would be good
oh I've just enough to get air and HP
this is good this is good this is good
this is good this is good
I'm using my nodes for something
actually nice so
because in this place I know I'm gonna
need the oxygen anyway I'm just having
more health is a good thing I don't know
why I haven't had that already
but I did not
can I get level three clearance yet why
don't I have level three
all right uppies
okay now that I got past the fun Acid
Bath that is totally functional and
definitely hey wait a minute
come here
come here give me your limb
I'll kill you with your own limb look at
this
I finished you off wow that's really sad
for you that was totally pathetic
that was pitiful even
oh I can still hold this and move oh
hell yeah
who wants one
anybody
anybody wants it
see this is the this is a game where the
protagonist makes sense of like I would
multitask all this stuff walking through
every doorway if I was in this situation
I might be lazy because I'm just playing
a video game but there's no way that I
would not be without defensive abilities
on hand at Alta of course you come now
right after
there we go that's what I like to see
come here give me you what oh my God how
were you that close
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay oh yes
I'm getting better at the Kinesis
grabbing which is good because it's
actually Gonna Save Me So that's not a
blade
there we go give me that give me that
oh no
foreign
blocked the projectiles with it when I
pulled it I'm amazing
there's more
somehow there's more where where
you stop
that's what I thought
is there more I hear more
there is more there's more give me you
oh fan blade
give
ow okay well that's rude
[Music]
okay well that didn't go perfectly but
my new suit seems to be a little bit
better at damage reduction unless I
accidentally used a
medical thing in the midst of all that
chaos in the midst of all that chaos
but that's good let's make sure I got
everything blapped up
okay
that was well handled you know you gotta
admit I did pretty good there all right
pretty good it's like I'm getting good
at the game
number good hello security this is Dr
croson Hydroponics something just hit
the hall near food storage we think it's
a rogue asteroid I have people injured
from decompression we need Medics and
crowd control right away
oh my God
what the hell is this detected everyone
out of food storage it's alive how can
that be alive
how can it be left so what am I gonna do
I gotta inject you
you mind if I stick this in your nose
I feel like there might have been a
better way about that but you know
all right Weezer with number one down
oh no someone's big mad oh you do not
you no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
oh you're different
whoa whoa what the
where did you come from
there you go
those little things still crawling
around out there
[Music]
all right
I'm ready for yours
oh you are still there
where are they
um
[Music]
doesn't she help people leave unitology
that's how we love her I hope she's okay
the unitologist here didn't like anyone
questioning them is this the captain
died they've all
snapped
aha they've all snapped huh
what I feel like it's it's clipped under
the ground and I'm just like
stuck I'm gonna go floor two just in
case
I'm gonna try to follow generally where
it's going because I know it's probably
a good bath and oh there you are you
really
that's where you were you were up there
this whole time where are you probably
one's on the third floor too
okay what's all this then
interesting doors doors jungle
well I can't I can't turn that off
how could I ever compromise the jungle
ambiance
as a matter of principle I shall leave
the jungle Ambiance online
I shall
and I'm going to just pop up to the
third floor real quick because I'm
willing to bet that it's there's no door
up there it's I think it's just like
observation and then you need to
or maybe I'm wrong I don't know ow there
you are
friend
God whoa be unto anybody that turns off
the jungle Ambiance if you turn off the
jungle Ambiance I don't think you're a
real dead space fan that I'm Gonna Stand
by that if anyone if you see or do in
your own game turn off the jungle
ambiance
can you even consider yourself a dead
space player and I think if you look
within you can understand that that's
simply not the answer you're looking for
uh cross are you here
hey you want some of this
uh cross you couldn't have waited for me
or something
as requested I've attached the latest
test result for that organic growth
we've observed on the ship I know you're
busy but we really need to run a joint
study with Dr Howell this substance is
absolutely fascinating what's most
incredible is the speed at which it
grows one of these bacterium reproduces
20-fold in just one minute that's why we
haven't been able to pinpoint any
specific origin point I think it just
seemed to be in multiple points on the
ship all at once I've never seen
anything like it I won't stake my
reputation on it but I think this may be
a genuine alien life form Professor
Hawley theorizes that it's a habitat
habitat Transformer the levels of
gaseous discharge are tremendous which
is why it smells so bad but to what end
we simply don't know what organisms
might exist symbiotically with it are
they out there could they be sentient
even I'll keep you posted it turns out
it was people the people are the ones
that could be symbiotic it's us we
and yes you should be terrified or
something I don't know probably
oh hey what's up oh
very scary can I get one of your limbs
can I get that yoink
[Music]
wow listen to that jungle ambiance
that is a slice of something special
that is really nice
all right Weezer number three you're
mine
where you at where you at Weezy boy were
you out Wheezy boy
where you wheezing at where's your
wheezing at so this that's great
empowering Humanity to something
something I didn't catch the rest of
that now I'm getting a surplus of ammo
because I'm actually using my kinesis
my Kinesis uh I'm still gonna hold off
on getting anything else because I have
enough ammo and so I seem to be doing
okay all right let's just keep rolling
I don't seem to be running into a
problem so I'm just gonna keep going
what oh god
well that was less worrisome than I
thought it would be
this is a cool place though
kind of dope not gonna lie
well
hey you got that out now oh interesting
oh my God
is there anything I can
oh wow you are really wimpy
I mean sure you got an explodey for an
arm
but just because you carry your big
bulbous ball sack out on your exterior
doesn't mean you need to rub it in my
face
save I like saving
hello why are you upside down bud
don't do that you're upside down oh it's
zero g
why is it a zero g environment
why
why would it be a zero g environment
good credits though love the credits
okay what are we doing here
yeah but why
oh hey
stop it
go to hell
where'd you go there you are I said go
to hell
I hate you it's a 1500 credits
oh my God I'm rich
okay which web man I'm gonna get lost in
here
cool hey spikies oh that seems
unnecessary
man thank goodness I don't have to be
bouncing off the walls I would just be
so unbelievably disorienting I'll never
be able to get anywhere
hey is that a baby I heard
it is
there's a baby I heard
hey stop that
hey hold on no welt damn it
and where's that other one
where are you
where are you oh who did that
show yourself oh you're in there that's
why I can't see take that
foreign
baby corpse
oh no not one of uses
oh great
this is unfortunate
and where's my
kind of hard to see ya
there we go
that's more like it is there another one
on the ground there
couldn't tell hey you didn't feel any of
that good I didn't want you to die
before I could do this
okay it's six that you get all you gave
was six
whoa who's screaming
why is it still screaming
[Applause]
I don't know why that's still screaming
for good measure
all right well that settles that
we're done here
it's good douche
where am I going what am I doing
this way we
I'm sure there's bound to be some secret
items and goodies that are easy to miss
in here but I'm going to not I'm going
to miss them on purpose whoa hey don't
do that
hey
1200 credits
hell yeah
okay I just came from there
ah got it
getting the hang of that
all right lot of D Weezer number four
here gonna be on the floor
from being dead I know they're kind of
already or kneeling on the floor but
whatever
foreign
hey were you trying to sneak up on me
what's up with that
[Music]
hey wait a minute
oh whoa
all right
okey-dokey then
man that was almost threatening
almost I could do with some more
I could always do with more
I'm gonna get some more maybe seven
thousand worth yeah that's good okay
thank you
all right going looks like a cross to
the other door so I'm not turning off
the jungle Ambiance because why would I
do that
yeah why would anybody do that
I'm waiting for an answer
is this oh
I think even whoa goddamn
goodies all over the boys fascinating
well this doesn't look good
um
I can't see
oh oh oh
Isaac where are you
help me
huh
how how do I help you
tell me
tell me how do I help you please I loved
you
well
oh
hey uh you mind looking down for me
that's what you get
all right good
whoa
hey wait a minute
nice
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait wait wait whoa
whoa
oh man I didn't precaution it
I didn't precaution at all
damn it
uh anything else
what oh my God you jumped who taught you
how to do that don't do that
don't ever do that damn it I didn't oh I
should have
I didn't
and that's what I get
that's what I get for being merciful
yeah whatever
all right did I miss any good buddies
a waste of ammo okay we done so let's go
Weezer number five get ready to die
off the cliff
into the precipice of death Isaac I
looked across his notes on the
oh God
yes what wait
he raised at me and
and sorry Isaac
keep going just a glitch on the cameras
look at my little brother
stupid right that's just
that's not possible
yeah not possible only a hundo really
whoa
okay that that was supposed to be a lot
more potent than uh
and making me look like a wimp I
feel like I was very very strong there
and Powerful really able to
there we go
[Music]
I hear you bud
you wheezing up a storm down here
uh
oh I was about to ask how hazardous
turns out extremely well this is a room
for the big kaboom
hold still holds oh my God you can still
do that
do too
you dead yeah you's dead
you's dead
thank you
all right where am I going oh there was
plenty of things over there I didn't
notice that
okay in here I'll get the rest of this
stuff once I get this guy taken care of
oh
uh excuse me uh look down for me all
right look into this and then fall over
and die great thank you
hey oh baby what are you doing here
and look you're you're really a credit
to your team for trying but really you
had no Hope from the start
same for you
oh well this seems useful
not sure where but it does seem useful
anybody see where this goes
ah of course I'll help myself do it
don't worry everybody else don't even
pay me any mind I guess
hi
[Music]
whoa
and you're dead good
all right any jungle Ambiance in here
he
Kawaii
why
why would a secure a security card be
required
well okay but I don't have it so you you
know you can stop giving me so much
attitude and you can just tell me where
to find it because I don't have it
okay I don't have a security card I'm
not gonna get one just because you tell
me to
here
hello
oh
uh-huh
hey wait a minute how do I get to you
hey
oh key card
that's nice
hey
cut it out
what you you share all right I guess I
gotta go turn off the gravity or some
stupid thing like that
sorry no personal lease
foreign
gravity oh
had to turn it off
man that limb wasn't blocking my path oh
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
not cool
who else
I hope this is a weapon oh
that was that was actually ammo whoops
well I'll never get that back again that
is gone forever okay whatever all right
so there's got to be a way around this
douchebag Weezer six
get ready to be Six Feet Under
yeah that's it yeah that worked
huh
oh oh peace
hello
oh up here
foreign
that now
oh you're not
all right whatever hey dude I hope that
didn't kill you oh man I'm sorry I
thought you needed a explody here take
this instead
[Music]
hey go away
is that a brain
fully anatomically correct brain and
floating organs just right here
weird okay
we there's seven
you're ready to go to whatever you call
Heaven
hello
wasn't there another one down there that
I didn't kill yet though
I feel like there might have been
another one down there that I didn't
kill yet but whatever
oh no
oh
well that's going to be an unpleasant
surprise surprise that I'm probably
gonna forget about until it happens
all right okay all right okay all right
oh you silly you silly you so silly
pathetic oh my God is Earth I saw a face
oh I did see a face oh I don't like that
face Lexi and zoom in on that face make
everyone experience the horror of that
face
there we go you deserve that
okay I don't get any goodies for that do
I
ah great
okay then save
this
you're seeing My Dead Brother on the
[__] camera all this stuff
imagine what the marker could do in the
wrong hands
this is about CEC again
thinking it's some corporate [__] try
to take the marker you and me could do
something about it you're leaning pretty
hard on this deal
what was that
what was that what is hawking loogies at
me you what where do you come from
oh
what is happening where am I what is any
of this where am I go oh that was
unhelpful
oh that's completely unhelpful
okay
um
wow I really I'm at a loss uh this way I
guess
wow
stasis uh somehow that worked don't ask
me how
I do I know not
oh boy
please die
oh God oh God oh God
okay okay okay okay
can't see can't see can't see don't know
can't see can't see don't know but I
don't see cancel it can't kill me did I
go backwards
foreign
please tell me I didn't just go
completely in a big circle turbine
control
turn off turbine
Ah that's handy so I did not go in a big
circle I went the correct path I think
oh yeah all right Weezer seven I think I
said something about heaven
morning
thermodynamic purifiers malfunctioning
stand clear of filtration tubes uh
okay
ah boy
your ship is full of fragile equipment
please take her around emergency door
locks and other sensitive devices
uh-huh
oh wow
where do you want me to go
so uh filtration tube what exactly are
you filtering
I guess you know thinking about it it
would definitely purify the air if you
burnt it
a million bajillion degrees
come here stupid body
I feel like this has got to be more
efficient ways to purify something than
lighting it on fire well actually no
honestly
that's probably the only thing that
would work on a necromorphic like
infestation of some kind is if you just
did blasted a majillion degrees
unless the malfunction is that they are
blasting at a million billion degrees in
which case I'm very I apologize
what's all this then
hey
don't
gotcha
no I want that thank you
oh it takes long pulled all the
Regulators from the purifiers and crank
them up as high as they go [__] crazy
but all I can do it should burn off at
least some of the gas I think [__] I
don't know I have to try anything seeing
hadake puke up her own lungs deleted I
can't I can't be me oh God help us yeah
that that would not be good
and just the psyche of these guys going
through all this it is pretty incredible
to think about
no bueno
no bueno indeed
one second I know I gotta I probably had
to come back this way so I just didn't
even need to go this way but
just wanted to be sure
what is this storage
hell yeah
oh you're in here
I didn't know you were in here uh what
do you think about soup
you like it good
that was a nice gazpacho
I I'm aware of that okie dokie then
about this way
he's growling
oh yeah
[Music]
you still there
hi you were waiting
all right who's next
grow chamber all right don't touch I
don't know how you wouldn't touch
it's what
foreign
[Music]
outside
today
oh
my God
well uh that was lovely
um what why
uh-huh
I would oh I would love
hey how are you uh how do you think
about soup huh this is chicken noodle
make you feel all better real quick
thank you
you're welcome
it must have worked he gave it enough
enzyme to dissolve a Fraser okay I'm
unlocking food storage quickly get back
there and space the bastard while we
have the chance
okie dokie
why why oh
what's happening
well that looks like it should blow up
but it didn't
what's uh is there something in here
with me
sure sounds like there is
where am I going
oh hey
what are you doing there baby
stop
yeah that's what I thought okay
get back to the nice jungle Ambiance I
missed that oh nutrition systems
can I go in there I feel like I should
be able to go in there why can't I go in
there nutrition systems yeah there's a
whole thing over there
Diagnostics lab maybe later
okie dokie then
whoa
whoa that was weird
that's nice time for the big battle
Maybe
whoa
well that was interesting
um
seemed like it might have been a little
bit of excessive but at the same time
oh never mind
no take your time
well
oh my God me
okay
oh that was unnecessarily fast
that was unnecessary
douche
all right what do I need I have health
I have don't need this unless I did for
the boss fight maybe I mean if there is
one I'm assuming it's a big monster so
I'm assuming there's got to be some kind
of a
fight or something
[Music]
foreign
that'll do that's all I need probably
I'll go space it apparently quote
unquote I space it that's what I was
told to do so that's what I'm gonna do I
go put it in Sp hey what are you doing
that
stop screaming
what do you think you're gonna
accomplish with all that screaming
nothing
all right oh yeah
leviathan's too strong it's clinging to
the interior of food storage we need
more enzymes there's no time I'm going
in maybe I can cut it loose the
Leviathan has a 10 kiloton Mass to
really need me to tell you this is a bad
idea well I'm a lot of good ideas so
guess what's left
I got a big old kaboomi
I got a huge kaboomi all right how big
could this thing be
yeah uh huh what's so special about it
boxes
ten kilot tons what could that be like a
size of an elephant oh all right okie
dokie I gotta oh I gotta be worried
about a big old elephant all right yeah
very scary
all right oh goody over here
hey what's up big guy
well you cute
um you want to show me oh my God
oh there we go that's what I'm looking
for okay I was looking for like a big
obvious uh weak spot all right I can
dodge you oh what are you doing miss me
oh okay I'll just shoot it
well I won't do that for long because I
got these things dodging oh missed me by
that much uh what okay I'll shoot it all
right
just getting the hang of this everybody
so hold on it's a oh God no no no
grab that throw that perfect
come on
dodged you
I like the Doppler effect oh God I'm not
so happy huh
oh I'm running out of Road I'm running
out of Road I'm running on a road whoa
my God hello buddy
all right
you want to show me a big gaping mouth
and oh how'd you do that
oh
never knew I could throw that back at
you
I mean never until this time because
it's all new
oh man you're killing yourself my dude I
ain't doing nothing about it
hi it was a stupid debris in my way get
out of my way
[Music]
here we go what what happened
what what happened
what happened I didn't do that
toxic Hazard what do you mean toxic
hazard
I'm trying I'm trying
oh God
I'm trying I don't know what else to do
oh God oh God this way oh God
holy [__]
all right uh am I do I I didn't get any
uh like extra gas or anything
[Music]
oh oh
oh wait wait wait wait
sweet
nice
well
time to sell that stupid doctor how
great I am at killing big old 10 kill a
ton nothings
crushed the heads of Leviathan
he will be neat for those in the
wilderness okay weird thank you Isaac
come back inside
uh uh all right let me just make sure
there wasn't anything amazing over here
like this weird green glowy
what's with the weird green light
nothing just weird and green
box oh nice oh okay just wasted that but
all right
foreign
here and there I can handle
listen
Jacob
my Jacob
last I heard he was on the mining Deck
with some other survivors
but they were building an SOS Beacon did
they finish it
he said it was nearly done
but I haven't heard from them in
a while
I can't leave yet
I need to make sure the air is safe to
breathe but if you can find that SOS
Beacon call for rescue I will mining
deck okay got it and if I meet Jacob
tell him
I'll find him
he's all I want to see
okay got it if I find Jacob just give
him big sweat smooch
we might actually get out of this
nightmare we might
or will we I guess we may never know
who knows if we'll get out of this
because we're going into the void
I don't know why we're going into the
void but we're going into the void thank
you everybody so much for watching and
enjoying dead space with me we've got
much more dead space left for us to
explore so get ready buckle up and
prepare thy loins and as always I will
see you in the next video
bye-bye